foreign
[Music]
migration from xl2r but I'd like to
actually begin this presentation with a
story
so
this is a story about a modern migration
exercise that I did about five or six
years ago and it was from Excel to our
subject of this talk and
the ultimate outcome of this story was
that I really improved my programming
skills in the language arts so you know
this is a positive story right
but I don't think it'd be interesting to
tell a story about just good things
happening to me I think the best stories
have conflict and in the best stories
things go wrong
and this is a story I'm pleased to say
where the price of My Success is that I
ended up crashing the server
and it's it's doubly tragic because not
only did this happen to me I was also
having to use Excel day in day out and I
know people in the audience if you've
had that experience before that can be a
bit of a struggle
so let me take you back five or six
years ago uh where did this all start so
this started with my boss at the time
uh this is
my boss and my boss comes over to me and
he says Johnny I've got a job for you
and the job is this so
we have a model that we've configured in
Microsoft Excel
it's it's slightly complicated it takes
multiple people multiple days to
actually execute the model and it's
highly error-prone process so at the end
of it we often have to check that thing
if things have gone wrong there's a lot
of validation involved in this process
and personally I think it'd be better
suited to a programming language like oh
so would you be interested in doing this
so my instinctive reaction is yeah that
sounds great what's the model
so my boss goes on to explain it's a
statistical model
okay and it's also a simulation model so
at the time I was working in financial
services
and this was for a banking client and
what they were interested in was a
multiple simulations of yearly lost
scenarios
and
after those simulations have been
executed what they wanted to see was
well if you plotted them on a
distribution what would the 99.9th
percentile look like
and if you think about that for a yearly
loss distribution that's an event that
would only happen once in a thousand
years so it's pretty rare and the point
about this is this was not only a
complicated model it was something that
was quite intensive it needed to be run
multiple times and I'm talking 10 to 15
million iterations so you know I was
aware of the challenge that lay before
me
and so I dived into the Excel model
and it's you know it's it's kind of hard
to explain to people who haven't worked
in financial services or Industries like
this before where you come across these
Excel models and their monolithic
they're trying to do everything and I
think this picture kind of sums up the
feeling of uh walking into one of these
uh things
um
it's a bit like booking an Airbnb and
you turn up in a demolition house but I
I was resilient I was a resilient
individual and I understood the task
before me and I wanted to carry this out
and prove that I could do this so
I opened up a script a single R script
and I proceeded to copy the contents of
the Excel model into this script
and I basically did this verbatim
because quite honestly I didn't fully
understand what was going on in the in
the Excel model
and I'd also written on my CV that I was
an advanced user of R which wasn't quite
quite true but you know we'll live with
that
um
and I proceeded to write the whole thing
up this was painful but I got through it
I was really proud of myself and I kind
of thought that like by the end of this
like my boss is really going to be
impressed with this
um it's going to really change the
business
so I go away to lunch I click run
and I'm like great Happy Days I'm on
cloud nine
then I come back from lunch and there's
a message in my inbox
and somebody has sent an email and it's
not addressed to me it's addressed to
the team that's the first kind of sign
that you've done something really wrong
and someone says where's the effect of I
can't log on to the server
now I'm a junior Analyst at the time so
I don't really understand the
consequences that I can create for other
people so my reaction to this is well
that's it's a bit of a shame for you but
I hope you solved the problem soon
um and then inevitably you start getting
other messages so someone else says yeah
I can't log on
someone else inevitably needs this
server for critical work and you're
blocking it
and then eventually someone comes to you
and they're like do you know what's
going on Johnny
um my initial reaction is no but then it
quickly Dawns on me that I kind of do
have some idea of what's going wrong
um that very last shred of denial is
quickly eroding and I finally realized
that something I've done has caused this
mess
and I realized that I crashed the server
now
um I put a celebrator Emoji there
because I think this is a bit of a badge
of
honor
um if you're ever involved in this uh
you know treat it as a badge of honor
don't treat it as a total failure you
will come through better in the end uh
so
this was I just about this and it's kind
of a funny experience in hindsight but
at the time this was kind of a serious
issue so
I was working in an industry that is
dominated by Microsoft Excel in fact
excel's like a fortress
um most models are configured in Excel
and Excel is the most trustworthy piece
of software for many senior Executives
in these scenarios
there's a quote from The Wire I don't
know if anybody's seen the wire the
character Omar says if you're going to
come at the king you best not miss
and
and I just come at the king and I'd
missed pretty pretty badly I was lucky
enough to have a boss at the time who
was sympathetic enough to you know
persevere with this project beyond my my
drastic failure
um
and so
what's the moral of this story
uh what why am I here what kind of
advice can I give you uh let's kind of
analyze what went wrong here so
the first big tip I have
and it's really the biggest fundamental
problem that I encountered here is
you don't really want to copy or
replicate Excel okay now like this is an
obvious point to make people if you're a
seasoned programmer but
let's take a step back and put
yourselves in the shoes of somebody who
hasn't really written much code in their
life
so somebody who's only ever used Excel
before for somebody like that
everything looks a bit like this
and
that's a spreadsheet but if you think
about it visually it's a bit like a data
frame in R and
that's that's not a mistake Excel models
a lot of things using data frames and
whilst this isn't a problem in itself
you end up with a lot of excel models
which
have a few questionable design choices
so the first issue you encounter
typically in the world is Excel models
which start out with you know a few
number of tabs of slowly increasing
levels of information and you think
we're okay we're stable and then by the
end of it you've got hundreds of tabs
and if you're the creator of this model
you typically end up having a nervous
sweat anytime anybody else needs to use
it it's it's a very precarious situation
to be in and all of this comes about
because the most natural data structure
to use when you're using Excel is a data
frame object
um so you know this is one issue that
you encounter sometimes the second is
a lot of these models you can store data
just in a spreadsheet or in a data frame
so
you don't really need a database right
well not quite I mean a lot of these
models probably should be supported by a
database but they're not
and that's nobody's fault right like a
lot of analysts who have built these
models
don't necessarily have the knowledge or
the skills to even think about database
let alone Implement a database
certainly at the time when I was doing
this I wasn't aware of this as an option
now why am I mentioning all this these
are issues with Excel models but the
point is if you're migrating an existing
model into an R environment you
definitely don't want to be copying over
these design choices
um if you do this then you're only going
to reintroduce the problems in a
different context
so
what's my next tip off the back of this
so what you want to do instead of kind
of copying what's going on in the
existing platform which is Excel in this
case
you want to think about the structure of
this model so what you want to do is
abstract away the implementation that
you see in Excel and think about well
what is it actually trying to do right
what are the functional requirements
what is this model trying to achieve and
the First Fundamental step of this
process is where does my model begin and
where does it end and that can be pretty
tricky with some of these Excel models
they are so monolithic that it's
actually very hard sometimes to know
where the calculations begin and where
they end
but this is a process that you have to
go through in order to start unpicking
this object and migrating it across
so this is why I have this A to B
presented here so you want to kind of
know how do I get from point A to point
B
that's the first ingredient
the second thing is well along that
route what are the operations that I'm
applying to the data at point a to get
to point B
and if you're doing a migration
especially in r or any language really
these are really important things to
identify because
you will be able to encapsulate these
into functions and objects that you can
use in your programming environment
so this is a good kind of planning
scheme to go through before you actually
do anything
and the second thing kind of related to
this is you want to think about what are
the data structures that I need to
transport the data along this route okay
just because the Excel model that you're
looking at is doing everything in Excel
and you've got multiple tabs and
multiple bits of information hanging in
memory it doesn't mean that you need to
do the exact same thing when you migrate
this into r
in fact you could probably save a lot of
the hassle a lot of the
um overuse of this memory and all the
other problems that come with it by just
thinking about what do I need to retain
as I go from A to B
so let me kind of put this into context
with an example
so I mentioned earlier that I've been
working on a simulation model at this
time
now not to go into too much detail but
the simulation model in each outcome it
would generate one simulation which had
a set of 30 new numeric outputs across
30 different risk classes
and one stage of this model is involve
the task of trying to aggregate these
simulations together
so the author of the Excel model decided
that well the best idea that we can use
in this context is we'll take the
current simulation that you can see on
the screen here
and then we'll take the previous
simulations okay the previous set of
simulations we'll add that on to the
existing set and then we'll get another
set of simulations that is one row
bigger than the previous
and that would go on recursively until
you got to in this case the 15 millionth
iteration so yeah this this was
something you needed to execute across
multiple spreadsheets and it was a slow
process
um
but here's the problem right if you kind
of replicate this approach and you just
stick it in an R script
you're going to run into trouble really
quickly
um and it'll look something a bit like
this and this is like a classic problem
that you'll encounter in the r
programming world
which is copying objects in Loops
unnecessarily and unfortunately like
this is one of the key design flaws that
I had first implemented in my script
um which meant that this thing would
just eat up your memory and it would
keep on going for ages you you probably
wouldn't get to the end of this on on 15
million iterations
um at least within a few days so this
was a really like key design flaw in the
way I'd structured this
so how did I fix this in the end so
I thought about it in a more abstract
way and I abstracted away from whatever
the model was doing initially and I
thought well what I actually need to
generate here is a list of simulation
results
and that will be equal to the length of
the number of simulations I want to run
and
for each of these entries in this list I
just need a function that will generate
my simulation results across these 30
risk classes
and then I just need to run this again
and again until I get to the very end
and then we just need to bind these
together
so
this looks simple and like it was kind
of a subtly different way of Designing
this but this very different way of
doing this was actually like a massive
Improvement on the existing script that
I'd written
and it's small tweaks like that where
you think about the requirements what
you're trying to do which have quite a
significant effect on the performance
so
my key tip here as I've said already is
to structure your model
and the final tip I have here is try to
keep things simple so
one of the problems is and I don't know
what possessed me to do this at the time
but
um as a budding analyst I thought it
might be a good idea to you know try and
do a bit of parallel processing in this
script and I think this this was the
straw that broke the camel's back in my
case
um coupled with some of the other design
flaws that I'd implemented I was trying
to do
multi-threaded processing and it it all
went a bit wrong I didn't really read
the documentation properly and
um I kind of was over complicating
things right like was this really a
concern that I needed to address the
answer is no like what I really needed
to do with this process was start simple
and start with a sample of iterations
that I'm trying to run
and then I want to build this up
gradually profile what I'm doing
and work from there so doing the basics
right in these cases can be really
important
so
with that I want to thank you for
listening
um and I want to just leave you with
this quote from Bob Ross which I I
really like is that you know you make
mistakes and we all make mistakes in
life and it's a cliche
but I like the addition that mistakes
are just happy accidents right like now
I can just about this and I can be happy
about my accident because I actually
learned a lot in the long run
so
thank you all for listening uh that's
the end
[Applause]
[Music]